ein wunderschöner abend erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
fällt meine lieben freunde und das sieht
irgendwie aus wie das haus von spongebob
da die sonne gerade direkt schon unter
geht würde ich sagen verlieren wir gar
nicht lange zeit umgehen erst mal eine
runde schlafen denn wir dürfen gar nicht
langer zeit verlieren ich habe nämlich
wieder unfassbar viel auf meiner
to-do-liste heute stehen denn ihr
durftet ihr in der letzten folge
minecraft mit luca die gestern online
ging entscheiden was ich in der heutigen
folge machen soll und ich brauche
erstmal ein bisschen mehr zu essen fällt
mir gerade auf das ist ja nicht angebe
hier mit 5fu kartoffeln allein dass die
offen kartoffeln einfach so er ist 40
mal irgendeinen sour cream dip machen
oder so ihr durftet in der letzten folge
meinte luca entscheiden was ich in der
nächsten folge also heute machen soll
ich für diesen baum der extrem cool und
ich habe den kommentaren entnehmen
können dass viele leute mal wieder bock
auf eine entdeckung frei ich weiß wir
machen heute mit balogh den tätig das
kann doch nicht angehen dass er mir die
ganze zeit geklaut
[Musik]
weg mit dem ich hab ich das richtig
arbeit konnte und ich dachte mir wenn
wir einfach normal meine welt entdecken
und werde vielleicht ein bisschen
langweilig wie wäre es denn wenn wir
eine riesige gassi tour mit ball machen
wir sehen allerdings bereits unten im
inventar meine beiden bögen sind ein
bisschen schrott von daher habe ich mir
erst mal gedacht beziehungsweise auf der
to-do-liste zunächst erstmal stehen
bevor wir die tour machen dass ich kann
ich diese beiden bögen nicht in die
nämlich den jetzt was wir auch noch
benötigen sind einige diamanten denn
meine rüstung ist ein komplett im eimer
also hier ein diamant sondern 123 nehmen
wir einfach mal hier führt hier den
botanischen das sollte erstmal reichen
und beim helm packen wir ein zwei drei
darauf dass mir das auf jeden fall schon
mal fertig was ich machen wollte war
eine hose denn ich habe keine normale
hose mehr ich weiß nicht ob es sich
lohnt dafür meine diamanten zu verwenden
aber wir machen das einfach mal wir sind
ja richie rich so die diamant hose ist
auf jeden fall auch am start keine
ahnung ob ich noch irgendwo verzauberte
bücher habe und dass ich damit die
seelen läufer kann nicht nur machen
damit kann ich übersehen sondern besser
laufen aber sonst für die hose eine
verzögerung habe ich nicht am start
ich würde allerdings generell mal ganz
kurz sagen dass ich euch ganz kurzen etl
rein ball gleich time lab ja komm jetzt
glaub ich hab mich gab man hier schon
mal ein bisschen vorbereitet von unseren
weg also die komplette rüstung ist ja
bereits repariert ich habe mir noch so
ein paar andere ersatz seitdem es hier
gemacht einreichen holzschild da kann
ich euch direkt mal ganz kurz zeigen
wofür ich mir das gemacht habe und der
innen- und das habe ich in der letzten
folge erstmal tür zu immer wichtig auch
wenn ihr in real life house verpasst
wieso sollte man sein haus verpassen wir
kriegen erst mal mit rechts auf balou
sodass er mitkommt wie ja dann kommen
auch wir können starten meine lieben
freunde denn ich wäre
das könnten wir eigentlich auch noch
vorher eben machen allerdings werde ich
zuvor noch eben das schild platzieren
dass sich ja die blumeninsel für die
chicken nuggets machen wollte das möchte
ich nämlich in irgend einer der nächsten
folgen machen
das wird geil das wird so geil wenn das
zweite stockwerk oben drauf ist dann
auch die der pool im meer alter das wird
richtig sehen wer schiebt mich irre war
da hinten soll die blumeninsel hin ich
möchte nämlich hier die erde
runterziehen ganz langsam bis ins wasser
rein und damit wir quasi wenn wir von
hier über gucken nur blumen sehen und
dann sollen der hühnchen rumlaufen und
so dass wir richtig nice wir werden bei
lose halsband jetzt erstmal färben hätte
eine ganz normale standard rotes
halsband loch ich find blaue irgendwie
ein bisschen cooler am coolsten find ich
die farben schwarz und orange und gelb
auch aber wir machen es jetzt einfach
mal oder machen wir jetzt gelb ich würde
sagen wir versuchen es erst mal blau zu
machen geht das mit einer kornblume
bauer farbstoff blauen farbstoff nena
kornblume damit sind sie sollten wir
jetzt glaube ich einfach rechtsweg auf
balou machen können so dass der dann wo
ist er schon wieder da thomas bock auf
ein anderes halsband ko auch verrottet
das fleisch mitgenommen für balu damit
er sich ein bisschen was lernen kann
hier komplett stehen
wenn du merkst doch fleisch komme
hierher kommen bach sitzt perfekt
die sonne geht unter das heißt ich werde
noch mal ganz kurz ebene runde schlafen
gehen was ich allerdings auch
mitgenommen habe sie schon hier im zwar
ein gelbes bändchen das habe ich nämlich
nebenan hier aus unserem dorf abgebaut
auf dem kürbis da links des weiteren
habe ich mir auch noch ein bisschen
stärker und eisenwaren mitgenommen und
hat dazu auch eine werkbank falls irgend
welche werkzeuge kaputt gehen sollten
vor ort das fleisch wie bereits gesagt
für balu einige smaragde denn wenn wir
einen dorf finden kann ich mit den
leuten handeln eine schere und einer
kratzen holzboote da fragt ihr euch
jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal
warum das mir wurde und in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich für
meine villa an der seite wenn man
reingeht für diesen bus einfach einen
blumentopf und einen vertrockneten busch
oder irgendwie so verwenden sondern
sollen ihm die cooler aussehen von dem
ganzen meine chance geben und was ja
auch schon sehen ich habe mir eine menge
schienen gemachte denn das heutige ziel
ist nicht nur die entdeckungsreise mit
balu abitur jazz schweinen perfekt dank
habe ich mir schon gedacht sondern ich
werde auch hier fordere die bahnstrecke
einfach mal fertig bauen dafür habe ich
mich noch antriebs china habe ich jetzt
vergessen gelieben darum arschlöcher
hier vorne habe ich nämlich auch noch
antriebs schienen die sollte ich
wirklich nicht vergessen wassereimer
braucht man denen den braucht man nicht
mehr hier ist noch ganz normale schien
normal und das sollte dann eigentlich
reichen bzw war hier noch nie hier war
kein vertrocknet das fleisch mehr für
balu deswegen erwarten wir neben
abkürzung ich würde sagen ich bin euch
jetzt mal ganz kurz noch eine tl ein wie
ich hier den fertigbau
[Musik]
wir sind fertig meine lieben freunde ihr
seht schon man kann das ende da ganz
hinten gar nicht mehr erkennen
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine
flughafen landebahnen ich habe noch
einiges an schienen übrig die sache ist
allerdings dass ich ja auch noch von der
vorne dann irgendwie eine abzweigung
nach hier machen möchte woher das wasser
verlassen soll und dann auch noch nach
dort hinten das sieht man jetzt gar
nicht mehr so richtig da müssen wir ganz
groß wie ein bisschen vor laufen hier
eben da sollte die blumeninsel hin habe
ich ja zu beginn der folge bereits
angekündigt da vorne setzen
ein bisschen sieht man auch schon dass
fische hallo hier ist gibt villa und
dann geht hier vorne noch im weg rüber
zu der blumeninsel und dann hier zum
wasserfall hause wir dürfen allerdings
gar nicht lange zeit für den mann lieben
freunde setzen uns direkt ins ak 10
holzboot rainer so meine lieben freunde
wir bewegen uns in eine richtung die
sonne geht auch schon wieder fast unter
wir bewegen uns in richtung wiesdorf tl
[Musik]
so runter sind ja auch schon passend zum
sonnenuntergang hier vorne in dem bio
mann gekommen was den namen akazienholz
landschaft
ich lasse mir ganz kurz hier raus eben
aus dem brötchen und dann müssen wir
auch mal ganz kurz unser camp
aufgeschlagen denn ich möchte nicht mit
so vielen monstern heute zu tun haben
von daher gäbe es bettchen hierhin
platziert zack wie es ist nacht ich bin
früh schlafen meine lieben freunde ein
neuer tag erwartet uns hier in unserem
ein kraftfeld ich nehme schön das
mädchen immer wieder mit antivir begegne
bgb wir karte wir begeben uns rüber dort
hinten hin zu dem dörfchen was wir ja in
irgendeiner folge relativ zu beginn des
projekts mal entdeckt haben
ich finde dieses akazienholz baum die
jungen nicht wirklich sehr schön vor
allem wenn sie die sonne aufgeht und so
dass jetzt schon alles wundervolle hier
aus allerdings müssen wir ja unseren
kleinen treu bleiben um ein grad aber
nicht hereingefallen
wir müssen unseren plan treu bleiben und
zwar mit balu wirklich dass sie zu gehen
ich habe gipfel eine nicht mitgenommen
weil das bin ich mal greift nun an
jawohl herr ernst ich habe keine leider
für balu mitgenommen allerdings
verrottetes fleisch kommt ihr könnt ihr
bruder
ich glaube mir auch immer ganz kurz
etwas zu essen meine lebensanzeige da
unten mit 200 zeigt es auch schon
deutlich anders da hinten sind auch noch
hasen und hier haben wir diese teile
also dass sie sind die ich weiß nicht ob
ich mir das so geil vorstellen kann aber
ich nehme die einfach mal mit können
aber direkt ein paar mehr mitnehmen weil
ich vor meinem ursprungs haus also von
meinem starter haus hatte ich ja auch
noch einige bäumchen stehende wo ich das
bisher nur mit laub gelöst habe
vielleicht kann man das ja hier mit der
generell alles ein bisschen schöner
machen sagt sagt dahinden sie mir noch
gar nicht gelaufen da sollte auch gleich
erst mal hingehen ein bisschen kakteen
werde ich auch mal mitnehmen
beziehungsweise ich habe ja kakteen zu
hause habe zwar schon mitgenommen wo sie
nicht mitnehmen
ich werde mir aber ganz kurz die bei den
dorfbewohnern melden und zwar wollte ich
gucken was die wollen nicht mit mir
handeln dieses dorf worden ist
allerdings nicht weiter jungen balu
kommt hinter mir her und der täter
tötete sich ja der teleportiert sich ich
habe keine alleine mitgenommen abkommen
wäre das tnt in die luft gejagt
völlig unnötig einfach ich habe keine
leine mitgenommen weil ich finde dass
hunde frei rumlaufen sollten klar im
real life ist wiederum was anderes
allerdings will ich sagen dass wir es
mal in die richtung darüber gehen ich
werde mich jetzt nicht auf zuckerrohr
und keine ahnung was konzentrieren
auch nicht auf irgendwelche items sie
davor hin gerade rum lagen zum beispiel
der knochen und die spinnen jobs da
vorne mit den fäden und so das soll mich
erstmal nicht gucken ich möchte einfach
die welt ein bisschen entdecken und
nebenher ein bisschen mit ball hier
rumlaufen wir können ja einfach mal so
eine kleine runde drehen vielleicht und
dann kommen wir hoffentlich irgendwann
dann wieder hinten bei unserem spawnen
gebiete raus also da hinten war das
dörfchen ich glaube jetzt einfach mal
hier um da hinten sind auch so berge
also kein scheiß ich finde dieses aktien
millionen mit am allerschönsten ich
finde unsere insel natürlich auch cool
ist auf dauer vielleicht ein bisschen
langweilig aber diese akazienholz
gebäuden würden sie wird uns die
geschichte finde ich echt nice vor allem
da hinten auch noch mit den schneebergen
nach oben alter das ist schon echt schön
hier aus ich hätte auch mal bock
irgendwann in diesem projekt umzusiedeln
also irgendwo anders dann hin zu ziehen
und die ganzen anderen sachen hinter uns
zu lassen wir das hier ist eine hürde
darauf konzentrieren uns heute nicht
wir haben hier vorne auch noch ein
bisschen wüsten ausläufer hinten sind
andere kühe
mir wurde auch letztens in die
kommentare geschrieben mensch luca das
schaf wartet immer noch darauf dass es
in dem dorf abgeholt wird ich weiß muss
ich auf jeden fall denn jetzt auch noch
hin die die hühnchen können ich
eigentlich auch schon mitnehmen
ich bin allerdings eher mit balu
unterwegs von daher werde ich mich jetzt
auch auf keine weiteren tiere
konzentrieren denn wir möchten ja unsere
welt so ein bisschen entdecken und
einfach auch gassi gehen mit balu
von daher würde ich sagen laufen wir
hier so ein bisschen weiter im wasser
lang haben ein bisschen hier was zu
gucken
wir könnten auch mal eigentlich in die
richtung pilz biom weiter erkunden von
daher würde ich sagen laufen wir einfach
mal hier noch so ein bisschen längst der
kärtchen bäume langweilig es einfach
wirklich wunderschön finde diese ganzen
biome hier
und das sollte man generell viel mehr
wertschätzen in minecraft es ist so ein
geiles spiel es hat sich so heftig kraft
entwickelt ich weiß noch wie es früher
außer das war wirklich kein augenschmaus
und mittlerweile dieser standard witz
den man früher mal gebracht hat von
wegen guter pc aber läuft der minecraft
drauf an minecraft halt auch so gut wie
jedem pc gelaufen hat derzeit echt nicht
so ein anspruchsvolles spiel es ist
mittlerweile wirklich ein sehr sehr
krass umfangreiches spiel geworden und
ein auch extrem schönes spiel gerade
wenn man es mit shader spielt auf ultra
graphics und so ich feiere es wirklich
extrem von daher sollte man die
schönheit von minecraft respektieren und
auch generell mehr wertschätzen
allerdings würde ich sagen schauen uns
sommer kurz ich weiß aber
das ist höchst interessant
einfach mal sollen fürchten tempel sowie
kinder ist denn hier nochmal das comic
oder was ist das orange keramik ok
brauchen wir eigentlich erst mal nicht
ich werde mich jetzt einfach mal direkt
hier runter bewegen ich weiß dass da
unten so viele treppen türen sind da
sollte man nicht drauftreten denn da
drunter ist tnt und das können wir uns
nicht erlauben dass das in die luft
fliegt also direkt bei diesem platte
abbauen hier drunter seht ihr schon
alles ist voll von tnt und in den kisten
haben wir hier meistens ziemlich krasse
sachen drin nur verrottetes fleisch und
ein bisschen gunpowder ist das euer
ernst
es hat glück 1 mich verarschen trotzdem
an den ganzen kräfte noch mit was er mir
hier drin wir haben a ha aber ein
bisschen gold wir haben das hier haben
stärke sagte wir verlassen den wüsten
tempel und würde auch sagen dass ich
mich nochmal ganz kurzen dtl ein blender
dann einfach cool
ok ich glaube dass die kürzeste teil
bleibt die wg in diesem projekt hatten
die gegen jetzt eine halbe minute ich
mich nur kurz aus den wüsten tempo
ausgebaut oder habe ich ja gerade hier
gesehen dass einerseits die sonne
untergeht also ich hätte ihn normal
schlafen müssen ich wollte eigentlich
auch sein denn du bist jetzt wieder zu
hause bin
allerdings ist auch direkt neben diesem
wüsten bio irgendwie nice bio mich keine
ahnung was das jetzt soll
mir wurde in die kommentare geschrieben
letztes luca dem die eisblöcke mit
diesem mega seller diese biome die ich
auch hinter meister medium gefunden habe
mit diesem komischen eis stürmen
das kann man wohl ganz gut traden die
sache ist allerdings ich brauche halt
kein eis und traden will ich mit meinem
willen weil die mich die ganze zeit
nicht nur nerven also ich habe keine
ahnung was ich mit diesem 1 billion da
jetzt machen soll
ich dachte mir einfach haye kommen bevor
ihr das in der time lab seht euch denkt
hört sogar gar nicht kommentiert dass
wir zeigen euch das hoffen zumindest
eben ganz kurz die vorne gibt's auch
noch weiter ich würde aber generell
sagen ich hab ich jetzt mal ganz kurz
meinen camp auf das ist so das kleinste
kleinste insel wahrscheinlich in ganz
minecraft wo ist mein bett gegen
da waren auch noch kurz stand bei euch
so kann ich sonst noch so wenig neues
bild auf instagram hochgeladen
könnte man gern licon ja der esa luca
sehr gut allerdings erstmal in ruhe
schlafen gott balu weg mit dir aufstehen
so das bett nehmen natürlich
selbstverständlich mit und wir gehen
auch mal ganz kurz darüber dass sein
nämlich echt ein bisschen interesse und
nach vorne aus vor allem das sind da
vorne ich weiß man sieht oder muss ich
dafür dinge sind da bitte ist einfach so
ein baum direkt am wasser keine ahnung
wie der dahin kommt allerdings schauen
wir uns das ganze mal ankommen und mit
dem schatten wie ich hierher schwimme
ich schon sehr sehr schön alles geworden
in diesem spiel
ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen hier
vorne dem wunsch nämlich auch noch mit
ich hoffe wirklich dass das cool
aussieht und dass jetzt nicht grundlos
dahin gelaufen wenn der nicht wollte
eigentlich wirklich in die andere
richtung laufen die vorne geht
allerdings nichts mehr also ich sehe
hier keinen wüsten tempel oder doch das
nachladen
das machen wir bei loup wir haben heute
noch gar keine action und ich weiß dass
action in erkundungs folgen auch
eigentlich nicht vorprogrammiert sein
sollte denn ich möchte meine welt
einfach nur kunden durch ein bisschen
zeigen was abgeht aber das müssen uns
anschauen da hinten
das ist einen besuch wert jetzt kommst
du mich doch mit so also ich weiß nur
nicht ob ich bei luther glaube ich
wieder sitzen lassen werde ich keine
lust habe dass er stirbt die vorne sind
schweine aber davor da sind schon die
ersten also bei du du bleibst hier sitzt
nicht dazu ihr bettchen im zakk wir sind
im krieg hier fordert sind die ersten
leute beim jungen band der erste ist tot
wo ist der nächste hier war doch noch
einer eben kann der von der seite hier
ist niemand mehr da vorne sind die
außenposten die teile aber wir sind
direkt die nächste sack und pack und
sagte er es tot
und zack zack zack der ist wiederum tod
hier vorne die beiden nehmen wir uns mit
wir sind richtig gut ausgerüstet wir
sind gut verzaubert die haben gute items
und es kann uns nicht schaden dass so
viele leute sind klar die ecke den ball
wo getötet es war wohl sogar zwei bars
und noch einer tot- und du auch auf zack
und
sack und pack gefordert und sagte er
jetzt auch noch gut du bist auch noch
gleich tot um nämlich jetzt sagt wir
jetzt und tuba programm und bam ich habe
keinen einzigen ofenkartoffeln dings
gegessen habe nur halbe leben verloren
und wir haben alle hier getötet das ging
mir richtig gut voran ich gehe jetzt
einfach hier hoch ich will jetzt mal
sehen was wir da oben drin weil in der
letzten außenposten gefängnis zentrale
hier bei dem man nur scheiße drin von
daher meine lieben freunde ich hier in
der kiste haben dir einen waldbrand in
der kiste hier vorne befindet sich lesen
als braucht man nicht hacken häufig die
brauch armbrüster habe ich genug schwarz
eichenstämme die fällt also das ist
wirklich immer eine pure enttäuschung
hier
ich geh zur u ich mache da platzt und
wir fahren zurück zu meinem dorf treiben
das macht einen schön 7000 leute was
geht denn ab wie ich mich jetzt einfach
folgen
hier kommen immer mehr ab dass man
nämlich einen globus im bett
pottwale bett kommt dass ihm gestellt
erfreulich komplett
verfolgen sie 1000 von diesen komischen
alle tot also ja da hinten stehen ob das
stück aber diesmal wieder neue hier
vorne das ist ein komplettes kriegs wir
hauen ab meine lieben freunde ich bin
doch rtl ein
und bis wir dann wieder zu hause sind
[Musik]
das war's
abbau leben bin ich verdammt ich wollte
sagen wir müssen irgendwie eine insel
finden um darauf unser camp auf zu
schlagen aber gesagt unser camp
aufschlagen ich habe weder ein bett mit
dabei noch keine ahnung was ist das ich
dachte dass eine insel was ist das
plötzlich ging das ist sicher so
keramische fasste plötzlich entdeckt
haptik hat diese welt bei mir ne ich bin
so unfassbar begeistert davon keine
ahnung ob das in jeder mannschaft fällt
so ist dass man so viele sachen die hat
allerdings werde ich das hier jetzt erst
mal unsere kleine bisschen nennen und da
ganz hinten kam es von hier aus sehen
da vorne was irgendwo dahinten dass
irgendwas im wasser
ich meine das ist so ein ozean
monumenten tempel oder so und ich will
den auch entdecken ist ja dass wir
machen
ich stelle mir jetzt einfach mal hier
bis sich verarschen während wir diese
ablehnung haben meine lieben freunde
würde ich allerdings sagen dass ich mal
eben kurz meine bruchsteine nehme und
uns hier so eine kleine base aufbaue ich
weiß nicht ob das hier wirklich zum
piratenschiff ist und ob da unten noch
einen dingens ist sondern raum mit einer
chris doerk eine schatzkarte so nämlich
noch mehr pro jahr
wir sind da hinten ist auch noch eine
kiste das werden wir uns vielleicht auch
noch anschauen
ich werde mir nur allerdings jetzt erst
mal ganz kurz die werkbank hier
hinstellen und eine kiste kräften dafür
benötigen auch der glaube ich dass wir
vorne bauen wir uns auf jeden fall jetzt
erstmal eine kleine base und dann würde
ich sagen dass wir in der nächsten folge
einfach uns mal diesen tempel da hinten
anschauen
ich weiß nicht was mich dort erwarten
wird ich weiß nicht ob diese tempel
genauso sind wie früher aber so wie ich
mein schafft jetzt schon kennengelernt
habe weil du ich lasse ich erst mal an
die kommende bleibt erstmal drin wir
werden ja darüber fahren also wie ich
minecraft kennengelernt habe in diesem
projekt schon hat sich wirklich einiges
da drin verändert von er schreibt mir
gern tipps für diesen ozean monumenten
tempel und in die kommentare das video
wird übermorgen online kommen meine
lieben freunde
ich hab jetzt keine lust mehr hier zu
warten diese anderthalb minuten vorbei
sind von daher würde ich an der stelle
des heutigen wir jetzt auch beenden
der mond ist aufgegangen
so kann in solch gefallen hat dass er
den daumen hoch und ein video hier da
abonniert main kanal falls doch kein
teil der luxus seite und wenn ihr schon
mal eins auf die glocke
denn dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich neues video
hochladen wie bereits gesagt über morgen
20 uhr
wir entdeckten das monument und jetzt
[Musik]